bonsoir rien de si tu as oublié merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
quel bilan est ce que vous faites de ces
dix ans après la chute de mouammar
kadhafi un pays coupé en deux entre le
gouvernement d'union nationale a à
l'ouest à tripoli et puis à l'armée
nationale libyenne du maréchal khalifa
haftar à l'est le bilan est très négatif
sur tous les plans notamment sur les
plans politique parce que l'otan quand
elle était revenue en 2011 a dit oui à
la fois le gouvernement de kadhafi le
régime de gueddafi et surtout l'état
libyen les gouvernements tombent
s'impose par un problème les régimes
chose s'impose pas un problème mais
quand on casse un état ça pose un grand
problème je donne là de la première
définition des tas de max weber l'état a
le monopole de la violence légitime
autrement dit il n'y a qu'une il n'ya
que l'état quel droit d'avoir une seule
armée nationale et seule police
nationale aujourd'hui on a plusieurs
acteurs plusieurs hôtes agonie sauvant
pense qu'il y a les stylos et ce nom
c'est encore plus il ya le faisaient nos
sud quasi indépendant même à l'ouest il
ya plusieurs milices
même pas ils se mobilisent alors que la
milice de misrata au à zenten où
d'autres donc s'il la crise de l'état
libyen la destruction des est
bien la grande question qui va créer qui
va construire cet état évidemment la
libye n'exporte pas depuis plus qu'une
année son pétrole d'habitude exporte
plus qu'un million et demi de barils par
jour mais non par deux cent mille barils
au même mois par joie la ligue 1 souffre
souvent beaucoup j'ai beaucoup d'amis à
tripoli ou à l'est est toujours et mix
prix lors souffrance dans les quotidiens
depuis depuis 2015 on vient de le dire
donc il ya deux autorités rien si des
wikis ce parti qui se disputent plus tôt
le pouvoir même si vous avez évoqué le
sud l'ouest donc le gn a reconnu par
l'onu la haine
elle du maréchal after on sait qu'il ya
eu des élections la semaine dernière du
côté de genève à la tête du conseil
présidentiel libyen c'est mohamed ben
fille il a rencontré son opposant le
meur et chaleur haftar très récemment à
ce que c'est un bon signe est ce qu'on
peut espérer que la situation se
stabilise et espérons le moi j'ai
souhaité que ça passe par un consensus
pas par des élections pour une simple
raison c'est tout ce dont j'ai posé la
question et qui a élu les 75 digues et
les présents à genève pour que ses 75
ans le droit d'élire un conseil
présidentiel
c'est à mon avis une grande faute commis
par les libyens et l'onu doivent passer
par le consensus
un consensus pas par des listes et des
élections est aussi là les élections en
libye
entendez avant plusieurs obstacles parce
qu'il ya eu des élections en juin 2014
les islamistes ont perdu les élections
les résultats étaient négatifs pour eux
donc ils n'ont pas reconnu les résultats
donc on a eu deux parlements à tripoli
l'autre à tobrouk alloués à l'est
c'est ça le grand problème existe et
elle cette démocratie électorale en
cette culture de la démocratie en libye
j'ai des forts doutes parce que c'était
toujours une approche américaine
la demo placés sont des élections fait
en irak qui ça n'a pas marché
aujourd'hui ils veulent forcer des
tribus libyennes à faire c'est les
élections et souvent des protagonistes
qui n'accepte pas les résultats
donc la libye doit passer par la tuerie
de consensus et winter théorie en
sciences politiques
le consensus pourrait être garantie par
les tribus les bienne
les tribus libyennes joue un rôle social
et politique plus important que les
partis politiques mais là on parle de la
libye
de ce qui se passe à l'intérieur même du
pays mais il y a beaucoup de pays et
étrangers qui travaillent en sous marin
en libye
on parle d'un grand jeu géopolitique
mondiale qu'est ce qui s'y passe en
libye pourquoi ce pays est il si
stratégique c'est que évidemment la
france et une italie via la turquie les
etats-unis la russie les émirats arabes
unis même l'egypte 1 qui s'intéressent à
ce pays même l'arabie saoudite
c'est la richesse de la libye hip hop
est très riche en pétrole
je pense qu'ils ont les premiers
réservoir dans toute l'afrique dans tous
les conflits en clair donc sept ans
richesse attire évidemment tout le monde
attire tout le monde en pensant qu'à
voir une partie du gâteau libyen et nous
avons bien que les ingérences étrangères
en lipides sont très très fortes et
multiples en empêcher solution pacifique
et politique et durable au point les
libyens nous avons bien que la turquie
et le qatar
ed ils se tiennent les islamiser tripoli
l'egypte et les émirats arabes unis
aident et soutiennent l'armée nationale
est bien dirigé par le maréchal fali pas
à la russie a une position
la france les états unis d'amérique sans
un acteur l invisible mais qui sont fort
présents sur le territoire libyen par le
piller leurs alliés tueur musculaire au
système piliers de l'otan donc tous et
enregistrement des acteurs et projets
dans les affaires libyennes a compliqué
la tâche de trouver solution pacifique
et durable
dernière question riadh sidaoui produit
100 mille libyens ont fui vers
l'étranger n'est en plus de 100 cet
alibi est un point de passage privilégié
pour les migrants vers l'europe
la chute de mouammar kadhafi est-ce
qu'elle a accentué l'immigration d'un
vieux continent rendant les frontières
poreuses
c'est la destruction de l'état libyen
par le temps 2011
l'absence de l'état ça veut dire plus de
police nationale homogène
iny cette armée nationale homogène qui
sécurise les pays de l'est à l'ouest et
du nord au sud à qui crée un grand vide
un grand vide des vaches doux
l'émigration clandestine africaine et
surtout les terrorisme
la libye est devenue un foyer des
terroristes que ce soit de d'âge soit
deux cas d'achat a eu son émirat a
certes à titre d'exemple à certains
moments donc là l'idée aujourd'hui c'est
un foyer des terroristes et de
l'immigration clandestine pourquoi parce
que il n'ya pas un état fort et il n'y a
pas un états unis en libye
merci riadh sidaoui d'avoir nous avoir
éclairé sur ses dix ans donc de la chute
de mouammar kadhafi en libye
je rappelle que vous êtes le directeur
du centre arabe de recherche et
d'analysé politique et social à genève
et auteur du livre du printemps arabe à
des shows aux éditions apollonia